[Music]
it started as legend one of the greatest
of all one of the oldest of all
but every legend has a secret they have
been Gere forever in the shadows to
protect Earth from what was destined to
arrive a thousand years we've kept it
hidden the secret history of
transformers it started as a legend one
of the greatest of all thousand years
who've kept it hidden to protect Earth
from what was destined to arrive Optimus
Prime you destroyed your home
you seek Redemption
ah hey cool
[Music]
your daughter what would you say to her
brush your teeth work hard stay with me
boy in a band especially a drummer these
are trouble times without leaders chaos
reigns
two worlds colliding
you're all that stand in its way now the
greatest mission of them all to turn the
tide of human history
[Applause]
the imminent destruction of everything
we know and love begins
I'm not leaving you
my nose seems lost a few brave souls
[Music]
save everything we've ever known the
operation is over when I keep it up on
prime okay
on the state
and once I said
[Music]
for my world to live
yours must die
[Music]